اخبار جديده اليوم وحقيقه الصادمه بخصوص
قرش الغردقه اللي هاجمت الشاب الروسي
وانهت حياته من اسبوع تقريبا احنا تكلمنا
عن تطورات القضيه اول باول من وقت اصطياد
او
السمكه لتقرير وزاره البيئه او امس كنا
كمان تناولنا البدء بعمليه تحنيطها ووزاره
البيئه معانا اكدت بشكل قاطع انه هذه
السمكه ما سبق وهاجمت اي بشر ثانيا اليوم
في عالم روسي ومؤسس ورئيس تنفيذي لشركه
تدريب على الغوص في البحر الاحمر طلع
اليوم هذا العالم وقال انه القرش نفسه هذا
قتل سائحين العام الماضي الحادثه الاولى
صارت هاجم سائحه مسويه عمرها 68 كانت
بتمارس الغطس والثاني سائح روماني اكلوا
القرش حيا على بعد 650 قدم عن الشاطئ وقال
انه بكل حادثتين كان سمكه القرش حامل
ما بتقدر تطارد الاسماك عشان تاكلها فاكلت
بني ادمين انه هذه المره كمان كانت حامل
وراحت على نفس المكان اللي حصلت فيه او
لقت فيه فريسه سهله وكان ضحيتها الثالثه
والاخيره هذا الشاب الروسي
[موسيقى]